this is not a job for people who could
go to Harvard or could be doctors or
lawyers it's not a respectable job it's
a job for people who didn't like school
or people who never liked Authority it's
a good job for somebody who needs to get
a job because they pretty much burned
all their bridges and they're tired of
living free and day to day
my name is Greg I'm a bike messenger New
York City I've been riding for 14 years
my name is young Nick 24 been bike
messaging for about a year now
I start out in the morning and I never
really arrive anywhere I'm constantly
traveling to the next place it's hectic
you don't just do one you pick up pick
up pick up trying to be as quick and
thorough as possible and then you're off
to empty out someone somewhere is always
going to be like I need this from point
A to point B and I need it done now and
as long as there's someone on a bike it
can be like I'll do that it's not all
taking sunny days and wine and roses
the important thing is those rain days
and those cold days and those hot days
it's working those days and trying to
make some sort of steady job out of this
silly hustle it gets a little annoying
and my bother somebody on day which it's
like multiple people or just like kind
of looking down upon you for some reason
but at the end of the day like they need
you it's a bottle with the city it's a
symbiotic relationship that you have
with you know it feeds you
you work for it the city will only let
you go as fast as it wants you to like
you can't push that boundary that's what
keeps you safe we're all gonna get
banged up you're gonna get bored no
matter how safe you are no matter how
smart or how great a rider you think you
are it's luck the moment you don't pay
attention it's your life you have to
become one with the traffic you get into
a into a zone might start out slow you
know you get a feeling for it you're in
between cars and then you should
swerving the entire time and you're able
to like pick up and read where a car is
going to go but everything is just so
synchronous like you're overcome with
adrenaline and then all of a sudden
you'll find this a great piece it's
absolutely amazing you know I feel like
I'm leading the city on my own terms and
kind of winning secondly at the end of
the day I get to live in the city ride
my bike and traffic and get paid but
there is sort of a larger metaphysical
aspect to it messengers eliminate the
distance between people that space
creates so we kind of shrink the world
you're handing it to me I'm handing it
to them and that's face in between just
disappears it's up to you to live in the
world that exists and not wish it was a
better world